so you know how nate and i have moved
into a new neighborhood here along with
gail and one of the first things you do
is check out the neighborhood as well
nate and i took a stroll to explore the
rich history of our new neighborhood
that neighborhood of course would be
times square we learned about its role
in shaping american culture take a look
tony here we are the viacom cbs building
where is it in times square
360 thousand people walk through here
what in a normal day that's a lot of
foot traffic a lot of footage you know
what three hundred and sixty thousand
and two and two two speaking of 360 i'm
ready to check this out
[Music]
new york city first timers and old
timers brush past each other right here
in what has become one of the world's
biggest transportation hubs just behind
me there are a dozen subway lines or you
can hop on this double-decker bus with
me and sightsee with the rest of the
tourists
what's up fam oh i got a wave
nate while you're taking your little
spin through times square i'm taking a
walk down memory lane that right there
is the last bastion of your
grandfather's time square
adult stores peep shows and porn
theaters once lined these streets and
came to define this neighborhood in the
1960s and 1970s but that was then
and this
is now
in the 1990s the city launched a massive
redevelopment effort transforming this
area into a tourist mecca
lily tuttle is the curator for the
museum of the city of new york set the
scene for me what would this look like
30 or 40 years ago there was a lot of
adult entertainment
sex workers drug trafficking 42nd street
was really considered one of the
most dangerous
crime-ridden blocks in the united states
what turned things around in times
square one of the things that was a huge
catalyst for change here was the
revitalization of some of the beautiful
old theaters along 42nd street that had
been legitimate theater starting in the
early 1900s but had become
triple x pornographic theaters so the
history of times square is basically
it's great it's awful it's awful great
sure yes
[Music]
now even in its grittier days time
square has long been a favorite setting
for filmmakers movie stars like michael
keaton shot scenes here amy adams too
they even shut this entire place down
to shoot this eerie scene with tom
cruise and vanilla scott
now if they're not filming a movie while
you are in town don't worry you will run
into a star here there's captain america
oh
and minnie mouse and then in the back
with a head off yeah that's minnie mouse
from your childhood nightmares it's easy
to lose your head when you're walking
around times square
[Music]
times square has always been part of the
music scene here in new york
[Music]
it has served as the backdrop to many
high profile music videos
and our new studio was once home to
mtv's total request live
in the late 90s and early 2000s fans
would pack these streets just to get a
glimpse of their favorite musician
doma t pongo you cover entertainment and
culture for mtv news which is part of
the viacom cbs family right what made
times square the perfect fit for trl new
york city is one of the entertainment
capitals of the world and if there was a
ground zero for that that would be times
square and when you talk about the
studio audience it was almost like an
extra cast member that was the special
guest aside from the musical guest
people looked at that camera whining
through panning across that crowd seeing
that energy and you could feel it
bursting the screen
the man this is called times square is
because that building behind me the big
one with the billboard and the ball drop
on top that is the new york times
building and although the newspaper
moved on some years later this has
continued to be a hub for journalism and
for news
[Music]
and of course we know we're not the only
news organization around here so we
figured let's get to know the neighbors
and we picked up a little something to
say hello
[Music]
i'm tony this is nate uh we work just
across the street from cbs yeah cbs and
uh michael strahan of course is a nfl
player i'm a former nfl player he knows
me nobody's here
it's mike
can you can you take this and just put a
little tin foil on it with a note it'll
keep for a little while you can take it
you want one
it's good i promise
tell them to give us a call yeah
tell them we'll be at the house
[Music]
something tells me they're not going to
be calling you know
hey to robin and michael and george
we're glad to be your name you know what
we ate all that cake and fruit ourselves
we did it
it's the thought that counts we're also
very glad to be here also very glad to
be here i'm just going to ignore the
crowns we're just very glad to have you
i'm a tourist i'm a transplant
i do say this though guys i look at
times square and being here very
differently and you both look lovely oh
thank